it's time for a pick from the little
yellow book my personal guide to things
i really want to share with you and
today it's a fresh seafood fest
delivered straight to your door
i know i love that fantastic
city pier seafoods easy entertaining kit
i love this city pier seafood is a
family owned company that does all the
leg work to make sure you're getting
fresh sustainably sourced seafood
wherever you are and in this kit you've
got everything you need easily prepped
heat serve dinner party happens bacon
wrap shrimp scallops lobster crostini
ross do you feel like a king
that's a zero point shrimp right there
usually she's force-feeding me carbs
creating lean
it's so true i'm your literal nightmare
i would argue with you but she's right
there's so much more on the city pierce
seafood website and everyone in our
audience today is getting a 200.000
[Applause]
thank you everybody so much for choosing
to spend your time here today with us we
make the show for you so take this good
energy with you and we'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]